let's talk about the proud boys militia
which has been banned on Facebook and
right-wingers are furious if you don't
know what the hell I'm talking about I
envy you the proud boys are this
right-wing militia group that's led by
right winger Gavin McInnes and they
engaged in violence in New York City
after a recent speech McKenna's
regularly encourages violence on his
program and another story that we've
been following have been the stories of
bands of Alex Jones's Infowars content
on a bunch of different platforms
YouTube as an example Twitter facebook
spotify others Facebook has now
confirmed to Business Insider that they
are banning the proud boys and Gavin
McInnes from Facebook and from Instagram
Facebook's explanation as to why is that
they have clear rules about hate groups
that proud boys is a hate group that
McKenna's encourages that hate as a
leader of the group and that that's it
the proud boys are accused of attacking
protesters on October 12th of shouting
homophobic slurs of beating and kicking
protesters five of them have been
arrested so far and what's interesting
about the proud boys and horrible is
that their primary channel for
recruitment is the Internet they are
doing this with Facebook and and by
banning them Facebook is directly
preventing the growth of a hate group so
let's talk through the arguments against
this ban first of all the idea that this
is new is wrong Twitter banned the proud
boys back in August that was before they
beat protesters in New York City so
fewer people knew about them secondly
that this is some kind of double
standard and people are already saying
online what about auntie feh well as
soon as people associated with an Tifa
advocate for violence on facebook or
instagram or recruit people to commit
violent acts on facebook or instagram i
will be the first one saying ban them
you're looking for people to defend
violence on this program whether it's
from the left or the right it's not
going to be me maybe Pat will defend
but not me and Tifa is simply not
organized in the same way though where
they are vetting and recruiting members
in this way and thirdly pat there's the
free speech argument conservatives have
a very weak case here because Facebook
is a private company they have Terms of
Service Facebook determined that those
Terms of Service have been violated if
you want to change the law to force
Facebook to have to allow this fight
that battle but nothing illegal is
happening here whatsoever and we
actually have a piece coming up about
that paddle long-form piece about social
media and censorship and free speech in
terms of service we're gonna outline
that entire debate that's only one part
of this and the other funny thing I
don't know if you saw this Pat is that
there are people saying
mcinnis is Canadian he doesn't have
American citizenship and he's inciting
violence and a hate group why isn't he
being sent back to Canada but to which I
would say I would not hold my breath
waiting for that yeah that's pretty
interesting
I think this this case is more much more
clear-cut than some of the other ones
like Alex Jones and some other
conservatives getting banned from
Facebook and other social media sites I
mean Gavin McGinnis he went on Joe
Rogan's podcast he describes the proud
boys as a gang and said that the fourth
step for joining the gang and being
fully immersed in it is to commit an act
of violence like to get into a fight to
get arrested if that's not inciting
violence if that's not a hate group I
don't know what is and in you know II
should certainly be banned from those
platforms but maybe they should also
look into some sort of legal
repercussions - yeah and I think that
their response to that which as many
people have pointed out rightly so that
he said a bunch of this stuff on Joe
Rogan I guess we were supposed to
believe that it was satire I haven't
seen the episode I mean is it at all
believable to say it was he was merely
joking no I why I would say that if you
listen to him fully in context going
back and forth with Joe there I take him
at his word I don't think he was joking
I don't think it was the teracle I think
Joe Rogan was taken aback by what Gavin
McInnes had to say but McGuinness
certainly came across a serious
last thing on this I don't want to be
labor something that really isn't that
controversial does anybody find it odd
that the proud boys are a group of white
men who feel oppressed and emasculated
in modern-day American culture like they
present as alpha males but when you
consider that in modern-day America
they're saying they are emasculated and
oppressed as white men is that actually
alpha behavior it's sort of something to
think about